my name is Hamilton Marley I'm a
comedian a producer entrepreneur I write
stuff and then I tell stories and
hopefully people can find them funny
[Music]
good morning good morning
so first of all why did you bring us to
this place
um because it's in sug
I love Sugo as a destination for anyone
who's visiting Qatar and it's the oldest
Market in Qatar and the name comes from
means standing market and that's exactly
how trade used to happen and this shop
here is one of the oldest coffee shops
in subwagov and football fans come here
a lot Hattery comedian that's very
unusual
like how how I don't know how do people
respond to that how did your parents
respond to this when you first oh they
still don't know like it's a it's a best
kept secret thanks for telling them they
um they don't get it you know my I come
from an academic family my dad the
reason we traveled so I grew I was born
here and grew up in America and Ireland
and so it was very very Irish and then I
moved here and it was like I had to
people didn't understand what I was
saying so I'm from gizabeda over there
with you
to here can you pass this off please
[Laughter]
I would like some of these things you
can't say things right I want to keep
talking to you and as much as I love
this place do you want to go see some of
those yeah and take it for a spin
you go on
quickly all right let's go
after you madam thank you what a
gentleman my mama raised me good right
so we'll just have a little walk around
[Music]
so we're here now that do you need to
get anything from here what do you
usually get from the circle I guess I'm
waiting for a genie
foreign
I only have one Rolls-Royce not seven
it's such a hard life no lamp let's get
your boohoo what else so this is why I
come to work so all the smelly stuff
like
um and like incense and all that yeah
and then I'd get textiles but what I
love about it is you get to see all of
these colors that come from you know
everywhere so walking around the suit is
always like an explosion of color
[Music]
this is see this is how great Healthcare
is on Qatar that even Falcons have their
own Hospital
it's a fact look it's one of the Falcon
hospital this is going to the emergency
no he's got an appointment he's an
outpatient
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
there hasn't been a World Cup
in a place the size of a city
you know you can get from the north the
northernmost Stadium
in
like 45 minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
one of my favorite kind of
just as a
like art piece is 974. oh and I said
before that's built for purpose and then
it will be gone
you built a stadium out of shipping
containers
I just think that's fascinating
[Music]
but the main one is Khalifa Stadium
I believe and I think the best way to
have The full-on Fan Experience and mix
with everyone is that public transport
Metro yeah of course
and if you take the metro and the buses
that's the best way to get you to the
state
[Music]
tell me what they mean okay
inshallah has multiple meanings and it
all depends on how you say it inshallah
means yeah God willing God wills it so
shall be you say
inshallah
inshallah like inshallah means 50 50
chance that it's not getting hot it's
not happening
inshallah if it like if it's if it has
an E before it which means yes like yes
inshallah that means like
like we're about to in champ you know
like it's never gonna happen and it will
take violence to silence
well then it's like inshallah like
you're hopeful like like you said it now
inshallah
like it could actually mean what it
means inshallah
um what other words you can teach our
audience or for all for the fans who
come in here
hella hella is like hella hella yeah
hello hello that's like Qatar is
hello hello
it just means hello hello means welcome
okay um
means let's go
let's go let's go
our gummy Allah is like let's go right
now
[Music]
do you how would you pronounce
even in Arabic there's two ways
foreign
[Music]
I swear to God
equator
Perkins
cut it cutter cutter go and get yourself
better
he's going over to Kentucky so what we
do
what are you going over there for
[Music]
this is Lucia Stadium
[Music]
that's what I'm saying it's not a
footballing country and it's not ready
to host a big event like the World Cup
growing up we played football Barefoot
and like that was what we did as kids
football is the most
watched sport participated sporting in
the country so I don't blame people for
saying whatever they're saying because
they don't know you know it's our
responsibility as I thought it is to
showcase our culture to bring people in
and that's exactly what we're doing and
we're doing it for the whole Arab world
it's not just for Katha I thought it is
the host country yes
but qataris are a minority in Qatar it's
like 140 160 different nationalities
living here they all call this place
home
um yeah so can we go to
the Albert Stadium we're going to albate
Stadium where it's all going to start
yeah because that's where cutoff is
going to be Ecuador yeah other
stereotypes
um I don't know that we all have camels
I have never owned a camel I've eaten a
few
but I've never owned a camel nor have I
ever raced a camel how does it make you
feel as a Cutlery
a moment when the moment of Pride
finally gets here I don't think any
other country has been exposed to the
things that Qatar has been exposed to in
the media
and it's fine we're doing it anyway it's
happening
we will come they'll have a great
experience and it's the it's the Arab
world I thought it was the host nation
but there's so many different cultures
here
that are
part of the fabric of our identity
there it is you see look at it it's like
a massive tent in the middle of nowhere
and then you get there and you're like
what
[Music]
it's my favorite Stadium
I think people will
be in awe of this building this is
it's art it's not just a building
[Music]
yes yes yes yes yes
so this is it Albert Stadium did I
change your mind
becoming my favorite now thank you so
much thank you so much